look for
evidence of exceptional ability or at
least aspirationally like sometimes
these things get
messed up in
recruiting or the recruiting photo
beings ends up being wrong like i
sometimes wonder with tesla
if nikola tesla applied to tesla would
we even give him an interview
it's not clear
you know this guy came from like some
weird college in
somewhere in eastern europe i think he's
got some odd mannerisms now we don't
know if we should have an interview like
i i worry that that's actually what we
do instead of like
they should be like man [ __ ] this this
this kid's super smart
what does he want we'll pay him anything
that should
that should be the reaction if nikola
tesla applies you know to tesla um
ironically
but so i can tell you the intent is
we're looking for evidence of
exceptional ability uh and it really
doesn't matter if you want to graduate
high school or college or anything we're
just looking for evidence of exceptional
ability uh such that it would be a good
predictor for doing exceptional things
to spacex